yes we are finally getting a look at
hustlers now the first trailer for
hustlers won't drop until July 17th but
that isn't stopping the star-studded
cast from offering up some quick
glimpses at their characters on
Wednesday Jennifer Lopez Constance Wu
and Lily Reinhardt posted super short
clips showcasing their stripper alter
egos in the highly anticipated new flick
inspired by the viral New York Magazine
article about former strip club
employees who banded together to turn
the tables on their Wall Street clients
meet J Lo's character Ramona a fur coat
wearing exotic dancer who freakin slays
on the pole rolling around in cash let's
watch that again shall we
look closer and you'll catch Lily and
Constance in the clip - Constance tees
destiny her hard partying hard shopping
character in the film while Lily
introduced us to Annabelle a selfie
taking homebody who is taking to the
stage to make ends meet spotted in the
corner Keke Palmer who shared this sneak
peak on Twitter
Madeline Brewer and Tracy Lissette also
got it on the action showing off their
scenes with Jennifer Kiki and Liz oh
this is a big deal to me Kiki recently
dished about the close bond between the
ladies on set during a stop by watch
what happens live with Andy Cohen he was
mostly Constance JLo myself and Lily
together and then we saw a couple of
days with Liz Oh in a car D and it was
always a group gay party B who used to
be a stripper in real life makes her
acting debut in the film and Kiki said
when it came to those sexy dance moves
JLo and cardies talents are matched JLo
has this really unbelievable scene the
Jolly Zbornak yeah yes
I'm in Accardi I mean she knows how to
do with that and when et caught up with
cardi and April she dished on how she
landed the role the JLo call you did you
call her well she first spoke to my feet
and I she really wanted me to do like
this I think like the second lead role
and due to the fact that I gotta work on
my album I got like a little smaller
role because like I had to be in this
movie it's something that is like all
the actress in the in the movie I could
sell them like no no no this is how it
goes in the club that the movie is based
on like that's the type of clubs that I
work not the first type of clubs that I
worked in short this is like yeah this
was my life what can you say about your
character what can you tell you just get
all your girl be Nate oh hey Julia
Stiles also teased what fans can expect
from her as yet unseen character when et
spoke with her in April
I played Jessica Pressler who is the
journalist who who covered the story and
so I interview all the all the dancers
she's living sort of the straight in
their life and actually comes around to
really sympathizing and understanding
the position like the the position that
they were in that made them resort to
this and she couldn't help but gush over
J Lo's performance she is phenomenal in
this movie her body looks amazing
you've seen the pole dancing there's the
nails in the hair the makeup but beyond
that opposite her in the scene I took
everything for me need to keep my jaw
closed because she's it's not it's not
JLo it's like a different person and
it's so not a performance like I I
couldn't tell where it began and ended
so I think it's really gonna be exciting
to see her in this movie
[Music]